The last thing you need to know is that you have control.
If you're not signed in to Google,...
...you won't see all the social search goodness.
It's important to know that you always have control...
...over both your connections and your content.
As a user, you can always add or delete links on your Google profile...
...just like you can defriend someone on a social networking site.
You can also add or block your Google Chat contacts,...
...so you won't receive social search results from them.
And as a content creator, you can choose what content to make public...
...and which public content to be associated with your Google profile.
We hope this helps you understand how Google builds your social circle...
...and then, finds useful public information...
...from your network of contacts to show in search results.
The main thing to remember...
...is that Google social search makes your results more relevant.